Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
June 4th, 2018. What's going on?
How are you? Hi, adorne.
Lattie I'm in Dublin,
Dublin, Ireland. Um,
I've been on a fucking plane
for, I don't know how long. Uh,
we left to lax and uh,
what were you supposed to leave
in the afternoon? And then, uh,
there was some problem
with the hydraulics. They
back the fucking thing up.
They pulled it forward to back that up.
They pulled it forward like, you know,
two and a half hours later we finally
left, which is all good because, you know,
it's Don Rickles says in
casino rather, it's, you know,
spread it down here then you
know, up there. Right. Um,
so I was just sitting on the fucking plane
and uh, they didn't give us any food.
They get a little cup of water. That was
in two and a half hour delay. Nothing,
no food, no drinks or anything at all. I
was thinking I was on Air France there.
I was like, oh, this is how these
fucking people stay so skinny. You know,
they just leave you on there.
They don't feed you or nothing.
MMM.
So anyways, but I kept my mind occupied.
I was transcribing a pan terrorist song.
I find get into shit. You know, I,
I can eats up all the time.
Um,
rather than sitting there either do
that or a police solitaire on my phone.
It's somebody get me a deck of
cards, they're like, you know,
you can just get an app for that. And
like that is really a lot easier isn't it?
Plus I feel you win a lot
more with the APP, you know,
cause it wants you to keep playing or a
deck of cards. They don't give a shit.
They just want it done.
They got your money that don't,
that fucking solitaire game
though. Don't get it. Don't get it.
Because they've got like 50 fucking
ads every time they shuffle the cards.
Every time you win a game,
be time you move your hand.
They got like another ad and they put
the acts in a different spot every time.
If you don't really hit the acts and it
goes to another fucking page, you know.
So somebody gets credit for a look
of viewing a click and analyze.
I don't, I don't pretend to
understand these things. So anyways.
MMM.
This podcast is going to
be all over the place.
I'm going to tell you that
right now because I was
debating whether or not to do
it, uh, before I left. And I was like,
well don't do it before you leave.
It'd be more exciting if people hear you
talk to yourself in a different country
that allowed a new fucking flavor.
MMM.
The gaming this crazy room. Oh Shit.
My Room Service. Hang on a second.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
It just ate my fucking room service
and I put it on the news over here.
It's just like the news back home.
All depressing.
Shit I got with a gun though.
But this is the difference
between the U S in Ireland.
It was a 38 Smith and Wesson with five
rounds of ammunition when they said what
kind of gun? It wasn't how much
ammunition was area almost went aw.
Fucking hilarious. Is that um, yeah.
Not about gloom and doom charity
one people were Hitler killed today.
When a tractor went off, it's
fucking railroaded. Hash hate hard.
I fucking four key to what are up to
you down in Guatemala and she bites,
have a hood and habits,
you know,
great accents that everything
but just all depressing shit
at grandmother was later yesterday
when she was found half eaten by her cat
ff weekend of Irish store.
I'm
sorry, I'm fucking punch drunk. I
fucking just ordered this shit on a BLT.
Not the most healthiest thing.
There was no bacon in it.
It's that rest of the world vacant.
You know where it looks like Ham,
but it has the consistency
of fucking Lod was delicious.
And I ordered the side salad.
I specifically said side salad,
no fucking potato teach. Right? And
they still brought me French fries.
I have the side salad. But you now it
is. If you see fucking French fries,
sit there and there's a
salad, right? The Salad.
That's the plain Jane girl next door.
You want to fuck that big tinted
horror up the street. Right?
You're going to go after
that cup of potato dish.
Some fucking man. Is he
Manet's over here? He can't.
He can't have the ketchup over here,
although they brought up some Heinz,
European ketchup sucks. It's all
natural there. Yogurts sucks.
It's also all natural. You know, I
can't even get through a cup of it.
All right. If I'm not
like got it. You know,
at least four cups of sugar in
an eight ounce thing of yogurt.
Like that's not yoga to me.
Um,
I charity one year old retired harbor.
Tell you do we eat it up?
History would five pounds of aviation.
The town will show shaken up. They talk
tonight, optical out and go drink. Um,
this has been the Aa additionals um,
any ways where the fuck am I here?
I'm in Dublin. What did I just
write? Berlin is my password.
Fucking idiot. I really am done. What
do you guys listen to this? I mean,
I appreciate that you listen to it, but
I really question you sometimes. Um,
gray sing about Ireland by the way.
It's going through customs now. Granted,
I looked like a fucking leprechaun.
You know, an older one. Who's kidding?
Who a bald or it looked like
a leprechaun uncle. Okay.
Um, they just let shit,
no work papers. No,
not that guys. Like, what are you
doing here lady? And I was like,
I'm doing a show all by yourself.
I was like,
Yep. He's like, all right.
They have a good one
stamp. Welcome to the country. You know
where the place you go to.
You get that fucking guy who looks like
he's in the Bourne identity looking you
up and down and you just start thinking,
why you making me feel like I
have drugs in my ass right now?
You know,
like I'm a mule.
Um, anyways, so I'm here
David. Hang on a second.
All right. Sorry. Look ingested
from the Goddamn flight. Okay.
You know,
sleeping in that recliner.
MMM.
Never. You fall asleep on a, on
an airplane. You're always like,
this is what it must be. What it's like
to be in a loveless marriage. You know,
we just don't want to go upstairs because
your wife's in bed and you just watch
TV to you fall asleep and your full,
you just lay in there and that
fucking lazy boy, you know,
or you've been married so long that like,
oh, I don't want to go up the stairs.
You just sleep right on the couch
doing that shit all night.
Um, I actually had a dream.
I couldn't fucking breathe.
I have that dream.
I don't know.
I don't do well on airplanes.
I watched the 250 greatest
goals in soccer and uh,
you know, there was some nice ones.
There was some pretty pedestrian once,
but I think it was also because
it's so fucking hard to score.
And he also said the top 250,
250.
Yeah,
like who has the fucking time? I'm glad
somebody did it. It took like it was,
it was the perfect soccer
highlight reel for an American.
I got to sit there for like 24
minutes and watch nothing but goals,
you know.
I bet goalies hate that
fucking highlight reel.
It's like a fucking snuff film to
them. You know, you don't scrape.
I have noticed about soccer is when you
score and your blasted by the goalie
high on either side,
it's e f they jump out of the
water like a fucking sword fish.
It looks like, you know, not at all.
What are they jump up like
like a swordfish coming
out of the water and what's
amazing is rather than just jumping
up and fucking trying to block it,
they always have to turn around and
watch it go in the net. You know,
it's like the Matrix. Don't you
think you could jump a little higher?
If you want some God damn concerned,
you know where the fuck is going.
If it got buyer,
you know where it is.
You know you can hear the crowd,
you fucking piece of shit. Right.
You know when it,
you're always fucking look at
goddamn soccer goalies there, there,
there were no nosy group of people.
I missed it.
Where's it going?
Right in the back of the net
know. And it actually,
it didn't even look.
Are there like safety
nets or anything behind?
Has anybody ever died.
Somebody blasts the ball misses than
that and then hit some fucking kid in the
face.
That's the only thing that was missing
from the Irish News. Oh, we legendary.
Went down to the pitch, took a focus
on soccer ball. So you don't know organ
here. They lay late, harassed
half six tomorrow morning.
That'd be really early fucking
funeral. Um, get it over with.
We're all fucking pasty over here.
The only thing worse than battery in
your son after he got hit in the face and
the pitch is getting a fucking sunburn.
My accident,
I can't do the Irish accent.
My wife reminded me of that guy that
met me at the airport when I was in
Scotland. Remember that? That story
I get off. And the guy who the sign
you had my name on, I came walking up
on my hay and he just goes below wall.
I'm like, what your
preferred bottle? A wall.
You saying do you prefer bill or
William Bull Bull.
Um,
how much
Jesus Christ is the only been 10 minutes.
Fuck.
Oh Man, I should have called in sick. Um,
you know what I always mean to do when
I go to Dublin is to take a tour of the
Guinness Factory.
You know,
I'm not, I am not big on Gordon to fuck
on tours. I don't want to hear about it.
Oh they get his family.
They fuck it. You know,
they first made their first battle care.
Just get to the part where I get my pint,
you know,
over here is where we put the hops and
the hops score and a big hopper Robert
Hanna at and they stood them up all shame.
It's gets on a bicycle.
It's got some paddles on it and he go,
he wheels around.
I would keep my voice or dumb people
think I'm really disrespect them.
MMM.
This giant fucking Queen Elizabeth
fuck is setting in a big room.
Like this ceilings are like,
this is like for shack or something.
Um, but I never ended up
fucking getting down there.
Um,
it's kind of stupid though, right? I mean,
I bet I could go online and just see
a video. I know what it tastes like.
Kind of a degenerate alcoholic.
Are you that you know,
there's a bunch of booze I like,
I'm not going to go there and see how
they make it salivating the whole tour.
Getting the fucking shakes.
Oh Man.
Would you want to just dive in there?
A 17 year old fell into a vat of Guinness.
Yeah.
Hey, cause he was burned
from a volcano and Guatemala.
He got to jump in the ocean in Guatemala,
but he was Irish.
So we took the pain all the way back
to London because he didn't want to
inconvenience anybody
with his own emotions. Um,
uh, I'm going to fucking new
phone over your mouth. Oh,
this is going to be a good time. My Show's
tomorrow night at the, the three arena.
I don't know what that stands for.
It sounds like some Illuminati shit to me.
Was it the three banks that
are left in all of Europe?
Are they part of the European Union here?
Who decided to leave?
Was it Brussels? No. Was it Berlin? Nope.
Was it Great Britain?
I knew it was Brexit,
so I try to guess all the Br.
Once I spelled Berlin,
I preempt the are Brelyn.
Um,
just to be interesting, you know, just,
just to try to keep it fresh globally,
you know? Um, anyways, uh,
how about those fucking Washington
capitals? I'll say it again.
How about those fucking
Washington capitals?
Tell you right now, if I'm a fan of
the Vegas Knights, I gotta be thinking,
what is my, what is our adjustment
to their adjustment going to happen?
All right, I'm going to go out and
this waste of what happened. Okay.
The capital's whatever the Fuck Vegas
was doing a game one at the capital's
adjusted to it and game three,
I did not see an answer by
the Vegas Knights. Okay. It,
uh, as far as my limited
knowledge of math goes,
they better fucking respond in game
four or this series going to be fucking,
oh, Ba, no, vet skin's going to be
on the cup. It's going to be great.
Either way. It's, it's a,
it's an incredible, it's
going to be great. I mean,
I'm rooting for the capitalist as a
Josh Adam Meyers and I'm [inaudible],
you know,
and then plus everybody down there,
they'd been waiting since 1974 the
Redskins suck the nationals, you know,
I don't, uh, you know these to be, the
senators in the Senate is twice they left.
One time they became the fucking Texas
rangers and other time they became the
Minnesota twins.
Then the fucking expos came down as a
nationals and they still haven't won a
title. You know, they're on
their third fucking marriage.
Actually, the senator's did want
a title in like the 1920s, I think
you don't think went to the
fucking White House. Thank George.
Washington was still there on it
showed up. It's fucking wooden teeth.
You have to sit there and
listen to some boring story.
How he said they made a bet on me.
It makes the teeth of his
fucking Betsy had as a kid,
I'm going to shoot the guy lied his ass
off that they had to come up with that
dumb ass story about I can't, I
can't, I can't, I can't tell a lie.
I chopped down the cherry tree.
What kind of ass kicking do you
think he got over that? You know,
when you really think about it,
back then there was no supermarkets and
this guy just chopped down a fucking
tree that actually had edible fruit on it.
You know,
I'd probably beat him with the ax handle,
knock that fucking powdered
wig right off his head.
Did rich kids wear
powdered wigs back then?
You know,
people would come up with key their horse
a shit. Fuck you guys. I've
been on a plane for 12 hours.
I don't give a fuck if this is funny
or not. I mean I do, I do care.
But uh, anyways, um, anyways, so, uh,
I watch game one of the NBA finals.
Uh Huh.
And I have to tell you when they fucking
reversed that offensive foul call that
basically every summit Jr Smith and I
can't get mad at Jr Smith cause I didn't
know what the score was either when he was
dribbling it out. I was going, yes, yes.
It was a lot of other people too that
thought that thought they were up by one.
MMM.
The game was over on that
offensive file. And, uh, you know,
I've never seen them have a little POW
wow in reverse a call. It's he, I mean,
I just,
I had like Tourette's when that
happened and I was so fucking upset.
And so once again,
disappointed by the NBA and the way
that they fucking run their league,
I was so mad. I walked to
my show that night. I just,
I didn't want to get in the fucking car.
I knew I had to go for a fucking why
didn't watch the overtime because I knew,
I knew the warriors are going to win it.
I've watched enough games that went up,
fucking want to kick in the
balls with a call like that.
And then the rain man,
dude,
and your team doesn't know
that you fucking tongue
tied and he runs out the, I,
you know what's going to happen.
So Lebron knew,
that's why he went back to the bench
and he didn't talk to anybody. Um, I,
I fucking, I had two shows in
La and I walked to both of them
at one in a dive bar.
And then another one at a little more
upscale place that wasn't quite a comedy
club. And I just, I just walked to both of
them. And I can tell you this right now.
La has an unbelievable homeless problem.
Holy Shit.
I mean, they are fucking
everywhere. Every doorway,
every nook and cranny.
There's somebody, you know,
wrapped up in a like a fucking cocoon,
a lot of mental illness out there.
It's unreal. It's really unreal how
we just fucking leave those people on the
street. You know, mentally ill people.
No, they used to have those as
silence. She can't. Yeah. I don't know.
That didn't work.
I Dunno.
I just need to try to take care of him.
It was really fucking depressing.
Then I was sitting there walking
down the street going like,
did I really leave the
safety of my car to fucking
walk amongst all these fucking people
who got God knows what kind of issues.
Right?
And I was standing there and this guy
with this really dirty shirt was just
staring at me and I'm waiting for the
light to say walk. You know, it's La,
you can't Jay walk. You'll get
killed, right? And then I feel him,
he's just staring right at me. I'm like,
half the fuck. Here we go. Here we go.
Oh, freckles. Couldn't take your car.
Could yet get all mad about
a basketball game. Right.
The guy looks at me and he
goes, hey. And I ignore it
because hey,
I ignore him again.
And then he sorta like walked around,
sue in my vision. He goes, Hey,
I looked at him, I go, what? And he goes,
are you Joel Mchale?
I just go,
no.
Then that said walk and I walked
away from and I felt him behind me
and I just kept walking.
Then I was walking too fast.
So then there was somebody in front of
me and then he's doing this whole kind of
looking back like, why is this
guy walking so quick? You know?
And I wanted to say that. Yeah, the guy,
hey, you don't need to worry about me.
It's the guy I'm walking away from.
Um,
anyways, so that's what the fuck I
did after game one. Jesus Christ.
But worries have to be the most hateable
fucking team I've ever seen in my life.
You don't get enough stars on your team.
You got to poke Lebron in the eye.
Jesus fucking Christ.
That's some shit I've
fucking girl would do.
Plan nerf basketball,
fucking disgrace.
And then Lebron gets out there with his
old ass body, takes a fucking charge.
I know his foot was work was moving and
I know that after they looked at it,
you know, they did get the call.
Right? But what the fuck they,
they've never reversed
something like that ever.
So like they were looking for a way for
the warriors to fuck it when it was just,
it just, uh, I don't, I don't
know why I give a shit so much.
What do I give a fuck about
either one of these teams? I,
cause what I'm rooting for is just for
sports to go back to the way they used to
be, where, uh, there was still
free agency. I'm not that
old when I was growing up,
but there wasn't these
pylons fucking teams,
you know, I dunno, somebody
sent me a thing about Lebron.
Could possibly go to the Celtics.
He better not,
I don't want that title.
You know,
I don't know, Bill, you just old and all
you do is complain. I know, I'm sorry.
I can't,
I just realize that the game isn't what
it was when I was a kid and this new
game, young people seem to be enjoying
it. Don't have a problem with it.
Should be the way where they had it.
When I was a kid,
there was an old man playing an organ.
Um,
anyways, uh, let me do a little bit
advertising rates. There's this podcast.
I'm not going gonna make an hour.
People, you know, by the way,
this is my last week of my forties.
This is it, man. I turned
50 years old on Sunday.
Can you believe that?
I was 39 when I started this podcast.
Way back when,
way back in 2007 man,
when a guy named George W. Bush was
president and he was a son of a guy,
George Herbert Walker Bush,
and he,
he was the vice president of a
guy named Ronald Reagan who who,
who used to be an actor
mean you fast forward look good thing
about everything that has happened since
I've started since I was 39 years old.
Huh?
Robots are gonna take over the world.
Miami's is going to be under Miami.
Miami's going to be underwater
reality TV show star
became fucking president.
We're still fighting the same fucking war.
That's the one constant.
That's the one thing you can hang
your hat on and be like, oh, okay.
There's something I'm comfortable with.
There's something I'm used to who
says you can never go home. Yeah.
Long was it before I understood that.
I've talked about that before. Right.
When they say you never can go home
with the fuck you talking about a book,
a flight right now and go,
Huh,
I never understood that they meant you're
going to go and it's not gonna be the
same people and it's just going to
be overwhelmingly fucking depressing.
Well, anyways, yeah, I'm turning
50 and actually feel good about it.
Ben got 50 push ups the other day. Right.
That means I'm not going to die. Right.
Um,
now my forties where my best
decade as far as my life,
I got married, I had a kid,
right, did a bunch of great shows,
got rid of all the fucking
assholes in my life. Cleaned house,
cleaned fucking house. Anybody that
was a fucking bigger content. Me,
you know, I got of, so obviously it was a
short list. Sorry. Easy joke. What do you,
what do you want from me?
Huh?
What do you want to have it on a fucking
plane for the last fucking 12 hours? Um,
so I'm looking forward to another decade
of experiences and knowledge gaining,
just living my truth.
I feel like for me,
my fifties are going to be,
no, I'm going to crush it.
My fifties I'm going to do
yoga. Eat a plant based diet.
Take a whole bunch of selfies.
Hashtag fifties hot,
hot,
50 some stupid like that.
What about the forever 21 is for an old
white guy over 50. Whatever that Hash.
Yeah.
You guys come up with the Hashtag you
come up with the Hashtag and I started
hashtagging and on fucking what is it?
What would the Hashtag App?
MMM,
you guys like Hash. Remember Hash
be your mother used to Macau.
She had the little fucking meat grinder.
Why the fuck oh Hashtag. That's what it
meant, Ryan. All right, let's, let's,
let's read a little bit advertising
here. Authority. Two-Year-Old.
All right. Uh, the black Tux,
everybody wedding season is upon us.
You're going to be doing it big.
You married a fat chick
and going out to all,
all of your buddies weddings.
Uh, when you're bringing a date,
you want to look fresh, but it
has to be convenient. Exactly.
You want to look the best you can,
but you don't want to be.
You don't have to be a pain in the ass.
That's where the black tux comes in.
Everybody,
the Black Tux has awesome suits and
Tuxedos and all kinds of styles.
And your rent them online.
Yeah, rent them. You go out,
you'll hook up your bang
and you give it back to him.
The black Tux offers the kinds of suits
and Tuxedos styles that would normally
be wildly expensive to buy.
And you might only wear it once.
That's right. You go to a wedding
and then you've got that suit.
You just waiting for someone to die. Now,
like the Emerald Shawl Tuxedo, it's funky.
It's cool. But how many times you gonna
wear that shit and Emerald Green Tuxedo.
What do, what do you, unless you were
the mascot for fucking Notre Dame,
you're going away that they one time,
right? They agreed alligator that long.
You look so great last night and I said,
that's going to be sitting in there
with the Black Tux. You can do.
You can do you.
Oh Jesus.
Okay,
well they're going to tell me to
keep my voice down. Hang on a sec.
I'm going to leave it on for this.
Yeah,
I was going to get yelled at.
It hasn't happened since I was New Jersey.
Okay.
Hello Mr. Buyer, which I
turned down or whatever.
What I what a lot of you have a release.
How many r's there around in the
English language to come to Ireland?
Yeah
cause we are second par.
Um,
poor park. We are fucking par. Um,
so try out the new looks,
do something different and take your
style to the next level with the Black Tux
free home.
Try on a,
you can see the fit and feel the quality
of your suit months before your event.
After ordering your suit,
after ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect.
Thank you.
If you went out and got Nachos
or something, the black,
the black Tux will send you
a replacement right away.
And remember how simple returns are where
it turn heads than send it back three
days after your event.
Shipping is free. Both ways.
Stand out at your event for the right
reasons with the Black Tux to get $20 off
your purchase,
visit the black tux.com/burr that's
the black tux.com/per for $20 off your
purchase.
The black Tux premium rental
suits and Tuxedos delivered.
Okay.
Simply safe.
You know it's important to protect your
home with the home security system.
Considering these fucking liberals
won't take away all the guns.
You might as well get a safe
fucking sleeping.
That shit. How can we protect
your home and your privacy?
That's what I love about simply safe.
They obsess over details like
no other home security company.
Here's an example. Simply safe has a
camera you can control from your phone,
but they want to protect
your home and your privacy.
So they came up with this brilliant idea
of private shutter for their camera.
Now simply safe wanted you to be
able to hear the shutter. Click. See,
no,
it's closed.
They wanted to have a light on it so you
could easily tell when it's on and they
needed to work for the entire
lifespan of the system.
I don't know what I'm talking about
right now. So simply safe. Got To work.
Testing different metals and hinge
designs for months and months.
The result in effective home
security camera with a thin,
lightweight aluminum privacy
shutter that will work every time.
It's the kind of attention to detail that
sets simply safe apart and keeps your
family safe. Simply safe isn't just home
security. It's home security done right.
Checkout simply safe
today@simplysafebird.com that's
simply safe bird.com learn
more about simply safe today.
Simply say bird.com by the way,
when you get home security,
don't get cameras in your house.
Just get them outside. All right,
cause you know what?
That pervert down.
They're hacking into your system watching
you fucking you laugh. All right,
me undies, everybody or you
jerking off on the toilet?
Yeah,
me undies, everybody. You've definitely
heard me talk about me undies.
You know the fund comfy
[inaudible] Mian days slapping your
fucking prick the dude dude to be ideas
beyond days with the fucking selfie stick.
But you got security looking at Yo.
Now they know you're come face.
What do you do?
You get a two pairs of fucking me undies,
one for your junk and then you face.
Um, you've definitely heard me talk
about me on these, you know, the fun,
comfy undies that feel as good
as they look to those of you.
You haven't who haven't tried them yet.
Listen Up.
You can get an incredible underwear
sent to your door with me.
Undies meaning no more hunting around
for the perfect pair at a crowded store
and eventually setting,
settling for good enough.
The undies is so sure you'll love
the first period and navy, not happy.
They'll do whatever they can.
He gets here,
the right pair and if they can't
keep them and they were fined you,
oh they're going to walk away and be the
martyr. No, it's fine. Keep it. Keep it.
Sorry.
I'm sorry we couldn't please you.
So it's really is risk-free to
try the best underwear ever.
And if you're already part
of the me undies, fam,
tell your friends about it
through their referral program.
That's like amyloid.
But with underwear,
they'll get a discount and you'll get a
store credit when, when still not sure.
Wow me undies has a deal for my listeners,
first time purchasers get 20%
off their first pair of me.
Unease and free shipping.
That's a team that's 20% off,
plus free shipping
and a guarantee that you and your me
undies. We'll be very happy together.
Get your butt over to me undies.com and
treat yourself to get your 20% off your
first pair. Free Shipping, a
100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] that's
me on [inaudible] dot com
slash burr and lastly,
but not leastly always headlining
stamps.com the US Postal Service is an
important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access
all the amazing services of the post
office.
That's why they don't want me to trash
the post office because they use them.
I get it now.
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for lettuce or
packages at your convenience.
24, seven, I got the hiccups
because they ate those French fries,
those freedom fries.
Uh,
print postage for any male class
right now from your own computer.
The exact amount of postage, every
time. Never underpaid or overpay again.
stamps.com saves you time and money.
Uh,
when you can use which you can use to
grow your business. I can mail any letter,
any package using any of my computer and
a printer and a mail carrier picks it up
well from your lips set of to God's ears.
Create your stamps.com account and
minutes online with no equipment to lease
with no longterm commitments.
Click print and mail and you're done.
Uh, it's convenient. It's easy, it's
reliable, it's efficient. You know,
what else do you work from an I use
stamps.com to send out my fucking posters.
Then I won't be selling tonight. I'm a
moron if I can figure out how to use it.
So can you,
and right now,
you too can enjoy the stamps.com
servers for the special offer.
That includes a four week trial
plus postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com and click
on the microphone and
stopped the homepage and type
in [inaudible] that
stamps.com enter a bar B.
You are our buyer.
That's a fucking English name.
Um, it's an English cetera name.
All right, 33 minutes in. Sorry.
The Tea Chai tea tree meditation.
All right,
should I just get to the questions
here? Thank I. Shit. All right,
so they have a gym here. Why did
eat those fries? I feel like shit
fucking hate when they do that.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know how alcoholics do it.
You know when they sit there and they
go, yeah, you know, no boost for me.
Then they bring a beer. They always go, I,
I, you know, I don't drink. I don't drink.
What's, if they brought a fucking crack
pipe up here, I'd smoke it. That's how,
that's how weak I am.
I don't even smoke crack.
Not at least. At least not during the
week. All right, great news. Flame. No.
Yo, Billy Nova. Uh, did
you hear the great news?
You finally have representation
on the Emoji front.
They added orange headed
people to the Emoji list. Nice.
Now you can let people you text.
No. You really look at the moment,
how you really look at the moment. You
say for me, I got to check these out.
Let's see. You go to the page.
Yes. That's what I would like to do
and allows looks like me.
They're all so young.
Add caused by Google. Stop seeing
this ad. Yes. Stop seeing this ad
already, but not interested in this
ad. We'll try not to show it again.
Okay. Get outta here. Beat it.
I hate when you scroll down.
The ad goes with you.
Like that person that's just
fucking tagging along. You know,
you're trying to hook up. It's like,
get out of here. Uh, Jesus Christ.
Would you look at these fucking things?
Yeah.
I don't look like any of these people.
Well that's nice.
That's not really accurate.
I mean they,
they should have at least one really pasty
couple of people of color in
there. And then they got some, no,
nobody with blue eyes.
Couple of Simpson's colored
people or Emoji colored now.
Well that's nice.
It's nice that they're doing that.
I better meet who at my
age sends out an Emoji.
Do you know you don't have emojis?
I use I all the one that
I used the most thumbs up.
Yeah.
Thumbs up. See what I love
about thumbs up is it means, uh,
yes I definitely want to do that.
Or it means like fucking whatever.
We got to get together sometime
man. Hang out, thumbs up,
not fucking hanging out with you.
Right. Or it could be like, fuck yeah,
get out there fucking drank.
Um,
all right. I should have made a top
10 lists of what I could do. What am,
what am I going to do here
to make my fifties you know,
the best me
lived your truth.
Do you realize like the amount of shit
that's going on in the world right now.
Okay.
And just to how self involved myself
and club and literally doing a podcast,
just talking to myself,
how's fucking self involved?
The world is right now,
you know, live your truth.
Be the best.
You've fifty's the new 40
you know, everything has to be
like, I'm on. That's, that's,
that's why you got those fucking assholes
who work out in the garage and then
they start running down the
streets. Everybody knows
the crossfit people. Right?
Everybody knows they're working out.
It's like we get it, Yo, I work out too.
I don't get to fucking start yelling
at people who haven't brunch.
I don't know if you know something that,
that right there,
you remember a few years ago they
decided to do away with bullying.
All right. Which you
know, is a great thing,
but I think you should be able to bully
adults because the fact that that's,
you know, it's not, it's out
of style to bully people.
Yeah.
I think is how crossfit actually exists.
You know,
if you basically categorize any sort
of criticism is bullying, you know,
how do you gonna know when you're acting
like a complete fucking tool shed? I,
I just don't understand.
I don't find those crossfit people to
be in any better shape than anybody else
doing any other workout.
And they had just parading up
and down the fucking street.
Like, I don't know what,
like, they're inspirational.
I Dunno. I've never liked, you know,
I don't like people that
do end zone dances. I just
don't like any of that shit.
It's just fucking,
and it's just,
it gives me Douche chills to look at
it. I Dunno. Maybe it's a good workout.
I'm going to start doing that,
you know,
through pull ups in my garage and then
run up and down my driveway yelling shit.
So my neighbors know that I just
did a set of 10 fucking pullups.
Yeah. Fill in the pan. Um,
Lebron is Celtic here. Kay has
a question. Hey there, Billy.
Not Quite from Boston. Uh,
what if Lebron went to Boston?
Kind of goes without saying that winning
with Lebron wouldn't feel as good as
winning without Lebron thoughts.
Oh, Jesus Christ. What am I the president?
You just fucking give me a half ass
fucking question. I gotta answer.
I don't know. Yeah, obviously,
obviously I'm a, yeah,
I would rather beat Lebron and fucking
have him just joined my team and then
everybody be like, well,
it's a fucking pile on team,
but gives a shit about your
championship. Yeah, obviously.
Thank you, sir. Those are my thoughts.
I have the obvious thought on that. Now.
I don't want that to happen. I would like
us to continue doing what we're doing.
We already signed a big free agent with a,
what's his face there that hurt his knee?
Uh,
ginger Vitus what the fuck is
his name? I Dunno. I'm not,
I'm on a selfie. I'm not, not a sound
something. I'm just not a basketball guy.
Um, and I missed all the games this
year. All right. I got a kid, man.
I got a kid in. I, I miss a lot of stuff.
The guy with the beard who
thinks the world is flat, right?
Is that the guy that's the guy that
go, I just want to see, you know,
it's like the New York Yankees, New York
Yankees, you know, they, they, they,
they built off of their farm team and
drafting and all that fucking shit.
And then they added one that, that's
fucking stud from the Marlin's there.
Can't get mad at that.
MMM.
Wait,
a couple of shrewd trades.
We did give up Isaiah Thomas stuff,
who I swear to God,
if he's still was still with the Celtics,
he would've got his own. He was like,
he's going to be a big Papi of the
Celtics a way I love a tail bill.
Did you hear this?
Did you hear about this whale?
MMM.
By the way,
has anybody seen that fucking
video, that poor girl calling up
her ex boyfriend crying? It's,
she literally sounds like the
impression me and Paul do when we,
when we do the crying thing,
poo or
she'd be like, hello, I'm
sorry I missed your call.
I really hope you call me back.
I love you and I do want to say
that I love you and I miss you.
[inaudible]
I'm not even,
I'm not even exaggerating.
I'm really sad that I missed your call.
[inaudible]
you fucking unbelievable. All right.
Pilot whale dies in Thailand after being
found with 17 pounds of plastic bags
and its stomach.
Yeah.
And also so get excited because
they have fucking ginger emojis.
Oh my God.
This is just what? What
are we, what are we doing?
Oh Man.
A male pilot.
Whales struggled for five days to stay
alive and Thailand near the Malaysian
border. I'll tell you, it's fucking crazy,
is those ocean currents of everyone. They
think, oh, it's from their, their plot,
Malaysian plastic bags.
It's probably, you know,
from fucking big fives sports in La.
Um,
Thailand near Malaysian
border after rescues found
17 pounds of plastic bags and
its stomach. Yeah, you can't
just eat one. They like Doritos.
The Washington Post reported on a Sunday,
but it ultimately succumb to its illness.
The whale died on Friday,
the post road in and I tossed it.
We discovered that Thailand's department
of Marine and coastal resource said,
we're 80 plastic bags
lodged in his stomach.
It's far from the first time whales have
turned up sick or dead from ingesting
trash
experts say that the whale likely
believed the bags for food.
Uh,
God.
So what are we gonna do about it?
What is the solution?
Plastic pollution throughout the region
is, okay, wait a minute. Let's see this.
Is there anything positive here?
According to another report by the nation.
A 2015 study by the Ocean Conservatory
and Mckinsey Center for Business and
environment found that Thailand was the
world's six worst offender for dumping
plastics into the sea.
So who's number one violence pollution
control department says plastic waste is
increasing by roughly 12% annual
with only 25% being reused.
The v,
that's pretty good that we were used 25%
that's better than what we used to do.
The vast majority of it is plastic bags.
The Bangkok Post writes that the 23
we're never going to get that shit out of
the ocean by the way.
It's like we just switched the cloth bags.
Oh my God,
we are a fucking plague with shoes.
Bill Hicks said that fucking 25 years ago,
the Bangkok Post writes that the 23
coastal provinces in Thailand generate
around 11 million tons of garbage
daily at those would be a year of which
approximately 1.1 million tons ends
up being dumped directly into the sea.
Plastic pollution throughout the region
is expected to remain a significant
issue.
As many Asian countries are experiencing
economic growth that is outpacing waste
management infrastructure. Here's the
thing. When the fuck do you put it?
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
This is when you,
this is when you need hipsters
because they're going to go,
go back to biodegradable shit.
Just trying to be cool, but they're
actually going to create a, hopefully,
I don't know. Oh boy. What
the fuck are we doing?
These fucking corporations,
what are they doing?
Which is all about the fucking money.
They don't give a fuck wars pollution.
They don't kill kids.
They don't give a fuck,
and none of these fucking politicians
as a goddamn thing about it.
It's just fucking unreal because they
need the corporations money. It's just,
it's literally, it's like a suicide pact.
How the fuck do you get out of that? Ah,
this is the press like the Irish
News. It's depressing. All right.
Massachusetts male mentality.
All right,
here we go. Hey Bill. I'm
excited to be going to show, uh,
your Boston show in the
fall, by the way, man.
I transcribed that fucking Metallica
song and it might double Bass player is
finally coming together.
I've just been sticking with it.
Now of course we're going to be
on the road for a couple of weeks,
but I'll get it back up
to speed. Um, you know,
Lars has like these four or five signature
licks and once you get those things
down you can kind of do a real
shitty version of all of their songs.
I still suck, but like I can actually see
I'm starting to be able to play along.
Um, I can definitely do like the 16th
note thing, but he does that little,
that triplet before the snare with a
crash, uh, China that he always does
that. Yeah, that one's a little
tough. Uh, love your podcast.
It's one of the things that
keeps me saying. All right,
I appreciate when you say positive things
about your relationship with your wife
and now you're so glad
to be on the other side.
I'm a 42 year old single female and
it's downright depressing around here.
I've been married so don't
need to do that again.
We just like to meet someone who wants
a steady monogamous relationship.
Unfortunately,
the guys around here seem to obtain their
intimacy from their relationship with
their male friends. Women are
viewed as an afterthought at best,
but usually as a nuisance or a threat or
you're in Massachusetts. I, this is easy.
It's an easy fix.
Get into sports,
get into sports,
start watching sports,
increase your alcohol intake and your
guy will be your best friend you ever had
a, why do guys have a mob
mentality when it comes to women?
They seem to think it's
giving up to settle down,
but don't they fear being
alone later in life?
Why grown men care what their friends
think and why wouldn't they be happy?
They are. Boy is living with
living a fulfilling life.
I'm cute in decent shape.
I'd say I'm a seven and a half in the
looks department and you're humble and
being serious. Yeah, decent
shape. You know, you're
honest. Have a fun personality,
can support myself.
I don't care about having kids,
but the schmucks I've been dealing
with lately make me feel like giving up
altogether and another mystery to solve.
Why do my friends and I
frequently see good looking?
Why do my friends and I pregnancy
good looking guys with women who look
miserable?
If you would mind taking a few minutes
to wax philosophical on the benefits of
relationship with the opposite sex,
that would be great.
Happy Birthday from a fellow
Gemini. Um, all right.
Why they got wire guys afraid
to settle down? Well, uh,
because women take guys for everything
they've got in divorce court all the
fucking time.
All right.
And like there's only so many of
those fucking nightmares that you can,
you can watch, um, before you're like,
why the fuck would I want to do that?
I mean,
that was my attitudes for
the longest God damn time.
And um,
when you get into a relationship,
a lot of times you are at the
mercy of the females moods
and you know, there's, you know,
there's all this shit out here right now
talking about all this shit that guy's
do to women. All this horrible
shit, but, uh, I went and
put the, you know, the winds,
the turn and pull back a little
bit and talk about, you know,
just this constant fucking like,
you know,
keeping you on eggshells. You
know, keep it happy, keep it happy,
keep her happy, you know, that happy,
happy wife. Happy life is what they say.
There's no rhyme for the
debt. There isn't. So,
you know, and everything is about
you guys. I'm just being honest.
You know the weddings all about you.
Valentine's Day is all about you,
the anniversaries, all about you. It's all
the guy. What are you going to get her?
And it's like,
it's all geared that you are so fucking
privileged and lucky to have this person,
but there's really not that sort
of reciprocal mentality. So,
um, but when you're a single guy, you
know, you got the world by the balls,
we make more, more money an
hour at dairy queen evidently,
or whatever the fuck it is that you guys
are saying. It's happens in, you know,
you hang out, you watch sports, you go
down in the bar, you talk some shit.
Maybe get laid, get up fucking blow
job, and you wake up the next day,
not in a relationship that's
really appealing and you
still have all your money
or a lot of it, it's appealing. Um,
I would also, you know, so I
don't know. I'm not, I'm not,
I know you want me to
say something positive.
I'm just answering that first thing.
Um,
you guys are terrifying and you act like
you're not when you're talking to men,
but amongst yourselves,
you know, amongst yourself.
I'm sure you're a little more
honest about like, you know,
the sanity of, uh, you know,
so many women out there. Yes. There's
just fucking nuts. The fuck them.
They'll get pregnant on purpose.
I mean, that they're fucking,
they'll bring a into the fucking world.
I mean,
crazy fucking crazy.
MMM.
God, I got to try to see something
positive here. Jesus Christ. Uh,
why you haven't Prob, well, you know,
you're also like, you're like me.
You waited a while.
MMM.
All those people that are like want
to find love and all that. You know,
you got a draft in the earlier
rounds when you're in your 20s,
there was a bunch of blue chip
prospects there. Now you're in your 42.
You got to try to find your
six round draft. Tom Brady,
that's what you have to do. So
it's going to be more work. Um,
but I somehow pulled it off.
MMM.
Grant, but I was 35. She was 25.
I Dunno,
I moved up in the draft. That's what I
did. Maybe you want to date a younger guy.
I Dunno, but I always looked at it this
way that you know, you're, you know,
if you're out there and you
seem cool, you're out there,
there's going to be your,
your match is going to be out there.
But like it's,
it's dangerous as I just trashed women
to go down that road to say they're all
like this or why do so many
people, blah, blah, blah.
You start getting fucking jaded.
And the reality is you could
do that about anything.
Why are most people fucking inconsiderate?
Why are most people fucking morons white?
Most people stand in a security line.
At the airport, rolling their eyes,
looking at you bonding at like,
can you believe how long this is taking?
And then they do nothing to be
prepared for when it's their time,
when it's show time,
they just start to take the fucking belt
off and all that and they become the
fucking problem. They don't notice it.
Okay. That's why I'm meeting somebody.
Awesome. It's so fucking special cause
there's not a lot of them out there.
So you hang in there and I think you're
going to find the person that wants to
have the relationship you want,
that you want.
And I think the relationship you're
looking for is what a lot of guys are
probably looking for around your age.
Right.
If I was you,
I'd get a divorce seat.
They're already had his fucking
kids already did that bullshit.
And then he can just fucking,
you know, hang with you.
You're not looking to get married and
you're looking at have any fucking kids
you can just fucking hang out and drink.
Cape Cod is and watch the pets.
Then you go bang, Bang,
boom. I solve your problem.
Probably not.
A wife wants to use my computer.
Oh Jesus. What? He got a bunch of
porn on there. Hey, Billy Bob Burton.
I've been with my girl for five years
and married for one and I refuse to let
her use my computer isn't because of porn
or cheating is because my PC is worth
close to 20 grand.
I used to work for graphic
designer animator and gaming a.
I didn't know they made laptops worth
that much. I even had it set up.
So I am not.
So if I'm not within three feet of it,
it is locked.
I have a piece of jewelry with an RF ID
chip that unlocks my PC when I'm near
it. Well, I got news for you.
Do it. Anybody who wants,
who knows anything about computers
can turn that fucking thing on from a
different computer when they're not even
in the fucking room. I guarantee, uh,
I told her even before we were married
that she will never use my computer.
She has never had a phone that wasn't
cracked or broken in the last time she
brought up my computer, I bought her
a thousand dollars PC of her own,
which she lost within a week.
Am I being too unreasonable or am I right?
Not Wanting to ruin my computer. Do
you let Nia use your computer? Uh,
yes I do, but like my computer's a fucking
mess. Um, no, I don't think, you know,
she hasn't demonstrated that she is,
you can take care of shit.
Here's the thing. If she, if she
was saying you couldn't use hers,
if my wife was like, you can't use
my computer, this is super expensive.
I do graphic designer ivy.
I don't want to use your fucking computer.
I hate computers. Have Fun with
your computer, you know, but um,
you know,
it probably makes her insecure because
that is where porn and cheating and all
that shit fucking happens.
So I'm choosing to believe you when this,
if you're not doing that shit,
and if it truly is because you have
this awesome fucking $20,000 fucking
computer,
uh,
then yeah, I, I don't, I don't
know what the problem is.
I would just sit there. You know what
I would do? I would take her phone.
Yeah. I would open my laptop and then
I'd have her phone right next to it,
you know, with the cracked screen. I go,
look at your phone, look at my computer.
What's the difference? Oh, get your PC
to honey. Oh, that's right. You lost it.
You lost it. That's right.
So now what have we learned
here? And this is the thing.
Let her get mad.
She's going to fucking storm away and
be all fucking mad. And then once again,
like I was talking about in that
previous one, she's gonna, you know,
do that whole thing where I'm, you know,
I'm saying the cal Dunnigan are mad at.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
she's just going to do that shit.
And you know what letter
you just, you just, you said
over that power all you want.
You know I'm right, and then
they'll get mad. They'll,
they'll switch out of the pouty thing.
Then they get fucking mad.
It's a whole goddamn process.
Just be like, no, you can't. You.
I would hold my ground on that one.
Just say, listen. Over the next year,
if you demonstrate that you can actually
be around computers without breaking
them or losing them,
you know,
maybe in 12 months I'll let
you look over my shoulder.
Yeah,
just tell her that's not how life works.
You have to earn things. All
right? Most of us do anyways,
but you wouldn't know that. Listen to
all these fucking feminists out there.
I think if you're a guy, you just
fucking show up. People give you shit.
I'm so hoping it becomes a level
playing field. I can't wait.
I cannot wait. That's going to be
the greatest fucking thing ever.
When they realize what a giant shit
sandwich, they still have to eat.
Oh, it looked appetizing when
you were peeking over the fence,
didn't it sweetheart? All
right, that's it. Everybody.
That's the podcast here. Uh,
thank you to everybody over here in
Ireland. Even before I do the show.
Thank you for everybody for a buying
tickets to come out to the show.
It's an honor and a privilege to be here
and you beautiful and reliable. And uh,
I hope we give you monies worth tomorrow
night. Uh, go capitols and eight.
I also like the Vegas Knights to their
coach gave a speech or something,
but GM at the beginning of the year
and an expansion franchise if you don't
watch hockey.
And he said,
all you guys in this locker room
are here for the exact same reason.
The last team you played for didn't think
you are worth being protected me right
there. They got the chip on their shoulder
and they'd been fucking mowing every,
everybody, everybody down ever since until
they ran into the Washington capitals.
Um, I'm going to try to find a
way to somehow watch that game,
although I think tonight comes
on at like two in the morning,
so I might be fucked.
MMM.
And I dunno if I can't,
I can't watch the fucking NBA
Huda fuck reviews a charging call.
The final few.
I've never seen that before.
My fuck. Oh my God. You know,
but thank God they did.
Thank God they did because I was able to,
I didn't have to waste time watching the
rest of the fucking game. And then I,
you know, I, you know,
went for a nice brisk
walk is good for my hat.
Um, that's it. Guess what
people were into June,
which means we are only two months
away from the start of football season
preseason just like that. It's coming
around again and the God knows the way.
There's like four days off
between every fucking NBA game.
You're probably just going
to have to do a, you know,
the last week of June and July and
then you're going to be right there and
you're going to be right there.
Although I've gotten back into baseball,
some back corner that giants game and
keeping score, eating the peanuts,
drinking that pocket course.
I liked it. You know,
I went down and bought some cigars
the other day. Right? Oh, Bill. Yeah.
Eat French fries, you smoking cigars
and drinking beer, what are you doing?
But joy myself,
um,
I walked into this cigar shop and I can
be honest with, and I walked in there,
you know, it's also a lounge
where people could smoke and shit.
And I have never seen anybody smoking a
cigar who did not look like they would
just totally fucking relaxed.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
In heaven, you know, like true
cigar smokers. I walk in no time.
I walk in, I have to go look
at that guy just sitting there
because I always have shit to do. So I
run in and I buy them and then I run out.
But I would see people just sitting
there and I think that's what the,
that's how you do it. Come down
in the middle of the day, honey,
I'm going out for a minute. Where
are you going? Not your person is.
Who is she? Her name is low. Uh,
Aurora emeralds. Lao, Aurora, Emerald.
All right, that's it. Everybody.
I will see you tomorrow night if
you're here in Dublin. If not,
I'll check it on your,
on Thursday.